[Music]
switch Morphers got young again shot
clock at eight good defense by Horford
forcing young back out on the perimeter
side said he's gone
lead back to five for Atlanta they work
it to the corner and Murray shot clock
down to three Murray he's got to hoist
it and Murray throws it right in the
face of his former teammate in San
Antonio Derek white and then he pointed
at him as well after he made the shot
he's really a terrific athlete he's
going to get better and better
[Applause]
had a good look but couldn't hit it 50
seconds to go again White's got five
fouls got to be careful young into the
lane
Trey young with the basket pushing the
lead to five again purple here this is
beautiful and then look White's trying
not to foul him and then once again he's
famous for that floater